black gold is often called but the oil
which once fueled the Venezuelan economy
is now poisoning its shoreline in
choking life we gained rare access to
the Maracaibo Basin one of the world's
most important oil-producing centres
it's now in frightening decline it once
had hundreds of wells pumping oil to the
surface now it's an oil graveyard the
water is horribly contaminated the
fishing boats are coated black in sticky
oil this is his sole catch of the day
were astonished there are any fish at
all in this environment it's incredible
that they're still fishing here because
500 of these oil wells are broken down
at least 500 and are not working but the
oil is still seeping into the water it's
covered in a massive oil slick this is
highly dangerous it could explode at any
moment it's a gas leak probably from a
broken pipe and the smell of it is heavy
in the air US oil sanctions will likely
make all this even worse but the
Venezuelan leader put an armed general
with zero oil experience in charge of
this and the crumbling infrastructure
has just got worse with devastating
consequences this is an indication of
just how busted the oil industry is in
Venezuela I think this was a former
platform just discarded and abandoned
and I can see dozens of other structures
that are broken and abandoned around me
here and the yet this country is home to
the world's largest oil reserves the
fishermen now traveled to deserted wells
to try to clean up their nets
nothing will get rid of the oil
apart from petrol which has its own
dangers they come here to protect their
partners and children from the / parents
but then seemed unaware or unfazed by
the obvious dangers and the geopolitical
war over their oil an American freeze on
buying the Venezuelan oil is meant to
topple Nicolas Maduro instead he seems
to have found another buyer in the
Russians and a while the country's
citizens suffer moderate to a rocket m43
we can see constantly every day they are
floating in the water because we have to
do work in this conditions every day
we're used to the goose now our skin
will get sore because of Washington so
much so much with the gasoline the oil
exports to America were once the biggest
source of income for the Nicolas Maduro
regime but plunged 40 percent in a
single week if the sanctions don't
result in what the US is pushing for an
even bigger humanitarian and
environmental catastrophe beckons for
the Venezuelan people I feel my heart is
Reagan you didn't see that this in the
past it's why they pay yeah right here
it was clearly only sand yeah
even the puppies are covered in oil
stains here the fishermen living in the
basin should have been the first
benefactors of the country's huge amount
of black gold instead the economies have
since Nicolas Maduro came to power
the US oil sanctions will shrink it
further on Venezuela z-- next generation
is likely to be left to clean up the
mess Alex for third Sky News in
Maracaibo Venezuela